foreign
to receive the incoming calls from
Bettors the bookmaker relies on several
devices which may keep his location or
private phone Secret
remember when gambling on Sports was
illegal in America
gambling was something that was in the
shadows around Sports and it was
considered unseemly primary interest I
have is an Integrity of the game so
that's why we've opposed Sports gambling
in the past
today the idea of sports gambling once
being illegal almost seems quaint the
NFL is finally here and I know you're
ready to gamble this is probably going
to be one of the most heavily bet props
in the game what are some strategies for
teasers in your eyes play them just play
them once allowed only in Nevada betting
on sports is now legal in more than 31
states with more on the docket to say
the floodgates have opened it's putting
it mildly this is the largest and
fastest growth of gambling in our
nation's history legal sports betting in
the US went from less than five billion
dollars in the Vets placed in 2018 to 57
billion in 2021 and an estimate of 200
billion overall in 2023
Showtime A-list celebrities billion
dollar marketing budgets Partnerships
with every major sports League Today
sports betting is impossible to avoid
and the top sports gambling companies
work more like Facebook and Google than
a Las Vegas casino using big data to
encourage more bets from users while
simultaneously keeping down Big Winners
what we see with online sports betting
and mobile sports apps looks a lot more
like a slot machine than traditional
sports betting we know that there will
be some people for whom this expansion
will cause devastating problems
Sports gambling is a progressive illness
when you're a compulsive Gambler and
they're giving you all these extra
propositions and they're giving you this
live betting you have no chance
whatsoever
unfortunately the history of legalized
gambling in America is replete with
failures of government and failures of
operators to really seriously consider
balancing the social costs with the
economic gains so while Sports is a
multi-billion dollar industry it's
possible the costs May outweigh the
games
foreign
[Music]
DraftKings are the Undisputed Giants of
sports betting just turn on your TV
during any sporting event but they
didn't start out that way they started
as daily fantasy companies or DFCS daily
fantasy sports plays by its own rule set
you have to create your own lineup
there's a salary cap you enter into
these tournaments you pay your entry fee
and then you win a prize depending on
how you perform under the rules of that
contest there were a few others doing it
FanDuel draft street so it was really
just you know daily fantasy sports that
we were pitching the question at the
time was it considered gambling fantasy
sports was in something of a gray area
it was viewed by some states as a form
of gambling and before that Supreme
Court ruling that wasn't allowed you
couldn't gamble on Sports we didn't
really understand the political angle
that could potentially ensue we just
thought fantasy sports is a skill game
that's kind of settled and we went about
building it in such a way oh I were two
billion bucks thanks to draftkings.com
in 2015 daily fantasy sports there was
quite a bit of investment into FanDuel
and into our primary competitor and that
money fueled a land grab for customers
which generate a lot of advertising that
advertising caught the attention of
regulators who wanted to understand
better what our product was probably the
most high profile was the New York
attorney general because effective this
morning DraftKings and FanDuel have both
ceased and assisted from taking bets
from New Yorkers daily fantasy sports
operators are free to go to the
legislature and the governor if they
want to change the law
which is exactly what they did
eventually DraftKings and FanDuel ended
up paying six million dollars each in
separate settlements with the New York
attorney general over false advertising
claims that settlement paved the way for
them to be welcomed into the club and
ended up becoming something of a soft
launch for these companies it's a way
for the leagues to get comfortable with
them once New York broke in our favor it
was clear that that was the trend that
states were going down we could start
focusing on the path forward instead of
fighting for our lives and defending
ourselves
breaking news to supreme court this
morning striking down the federal ban on
sports betting now it leaves it up to
the state
overnight because the Supreme Court
ruling in 2018 allowed States other than
Nevada to legalize gambling on Sports
gambling has become mainstream in
America
it was certainly a happy day in the
office as we all kind of frantically
looked at our laptops and scanned
through the decision together
it didn't take long within about a year
sports betting was already bigger than
daily fantasy Sports
after the ruling the major American
professional sports leagues who all at
one point denounced Sports gambling
started doing a rapid 180. but I think
it's ultimately a positive thing and our
view is both from an Integrity
standpoint and a regulatory standpoint
and ultimately for States and federal
jurisdictions raise tax it should be a
regulated industry first the NBA partner
with the sports betting companies and
then the NFL MLB and NHL quickly
followed and now within four years of
legalization it's legal in more than 30
states that covers 35 percent of the
population while California
overwhelmingly voted against legalized
sports betting it's still pending in a
number of very big markets
but for the markets where it is legal
the race for customer acquisition was on
here are tonight's betting odds brought
to you by FanDuel sports book the number
one over at DraftKings right now it's
free to enter a thousand dollars in free
prizes DraftKings and FanDuel have
dominated the market boasting between 60
to 70 percent of the entire sports
betting market and they've spent massive
amounts to get there you know what to do
you're seeing very expensive celebrities
Jamie Foxx Patton Oswald advertising
Sports books advertising betting apps
and you're seeing it in these
Partnerships with sports teams and just
about every major State that's legalized
Sports gambling Sky High advertising
budgets have kept both companies in the
red for years DraftKings Revenue was 1.3
billion in 2021 it's sales and marketing
expenses that were almost a billion
dollars in 2021 and that was double from
the previous year we expect our first
profitable quarter on an adjusted ebitda
basis to be Q4 of next year
FanDuel however is the first to actually
post a profit we were the first sports
book in the U.S to report that we were
profitable in the second quarter of this
year that we expect to be profitable for
the full year in 2023
the other side of the coin when it comes
to Growing the sports betting business
are Partnerships with the sports leagues
themselves
these Partnerships are hugely lucrative
betting apps are partnering with just
about every major sports team they can
because it's a way for them to get their
brands in front of viewers
so here at DC United in my hometown we
have a retail sports book we have retail
Sports books also at the footprint arena
in Phoenix the home of the Suns we will
have one uh coming soon in the United
Center home of the Blackhawks and the
Bulls in Chicago
as a partner we're not just a category
that they're selling we're actually
something that really is integrated into
their game into their Fan Experience we
need to be woven into the pre-game
narratives when people are discussing
the game for the leagues this is a
massive win it makes fans more engaged
than ever just think about it if the
Orlando Magic are playing the Charlotte
Hornets on a Monday night most people
won't care
but if someone has money on that game
well now they're invested in every play
we can help deepen the Affinity that
their customers have for the game and
deepen the engagement that their
customers have with their content looks
like you've got a bad case of single
game fixation along with the Deluge of
media marketing for sports betting comes
seductive sign up offers for free money
pick a sport place a bet boom goes a
dynamite the apps advertise risk-free
bets they advertise can't lose parlays
they advertise all these ways that
they're handing out free money to you
the lucky better I found that these
offers are actually too good to be true
I took up DraftKings on an offer of 20
bonus up to a thousand dollars so I put
in 200 expecting to get forty dollars
back one of the limitations of this
offer was that the bonus is awarded in
tranches of one dollar per 25 bet so
that meant that my 200 actually equated
to eight dollars in bonus money but if I
kept placing more bets on the app I
would be able to claim up to that 200
the hitch was that I needed to place
potentially thousands tens of thousands
of of my own dollars at risk to take
that to capture that money
I think our promotions are quite
standard in the mechanics not just with
others in the US but really with
promotions that have been run throughout
the globe for decades and more mature
gaming markets so once these sites
acquire these customers they have to
keep them there and they have definitely
found their hook the industry Hypes the
game within the game these are in-game
bets and in-game bets are seen as a
great growth Market because you don't
just Place one bet at the beginning of
the week and you're done in-game betting
is one of the great examples of where
the mobile online product really can be
so differentiated from the brick and
mortar product we have seen the adoption
of in-play betting again be a bit
quicker in the United States than
perhaps we anticipated
for decades sports betting was limited
to betting on just the games who would
win how many points the team would score
who will cover the spread
in-game betting allows the user to bet
throughout the game every pitch of a
baseball game every point of a tennis
match every play of an NFL game on a
free throw on you name it you know those
are things that I think customers want
and haven't necessarily been able to get
in the brick and mortar setting
this is advertised at you the whole game
long it keeps you thinking about betting
and involved in betting throughout the
game it really creates engagement at a
deeper level which of course makes
people bigger fans and makes them tune
into the content longer and pay more
attention to it and if your bat loses
mid game then you're pitched another bet
to try to recoup your losses it's
dangerous because it does have the
potential to keep you chasing losses
foreign
losses is maybe the most dangerous
phrase in sports betting
I think there's an intuitive sense if
there are more things to bet on that
creates more of an opportunity for
someone who has a compulsive Behavior
issue you look at the structural
characteristics of in play betting it is
extremely rapid while there is an
illusion of skill and control actually
in many cases those bets are just uh you
know it's almost like playing a slot
machine every five seconds you can bet a
new one which can make betting on sports
less about heightening the game and more
about getting a fix
when you put sports betting in a mobile
or online form it no longer is tied or
pinned to these particular sport event
not only can you play in-game on
multiple things continuously you can
also bet on after game things you don't
have to stop when the game ends you're
very hooked in and confirmed in your
behavior because of this constant fast
feedback and while only two percent of
gamblers become addicted to gambling for
the ones who do it has the potential to
ruin lives the history of legalized
gambling in America has never been
driven by concerns about problem
gambling and so as we enter this
unprecedented wave we're really
concerned about the increase in gambling
problems that will accompany the massive
expansion of gambling
[Music]
gambling really started to get bad for
me when I was in college
this is Joel Sofer a gambling addict and
the author of Never Enough zeros a book
about his life as an addict
it got to the point where I owed a bunch
of different bookmakers over a million
dollars
no
when they came out with these apps they
had all the proposition bats they had
the live betting so now I'm in action
all day every day from the moment I get
up I'm betting on international soccer
to the moment I go to bed I'm betting on
Chinese tennis
with the help of a gambling treatment
program Joel was eventually able to kick
his gambling addiction and is now
devoted to helping others
because of my experience in the sports
gambling world for so long now I can
share my experience strength and hope to
help other people caught in the same
addiction you want to educate people
that are in positions to talk to people
about the risk the dangers of this
Sports gambling
hey it's Craig Carter while the risk for
addiction is small both DraftKings
FanDuel and others say they are
dedicated to what's called responsible
gaming
by and large in the United States that
responsibility is primarily on the
individual but those who operate profit
from and regulate gambling also have a
role in responsible gambling should
always be a part of your playbook
responsible gaming is something we wake
up every day thinking about it's a top
priority of our business the health in
um longevity of the industry really
depends on not just us but everyone
getting this right I think that their
economic future depends on responsible
gambling the former employees I spoke to
said that there was always a
company-wide message that responsible
gaming is important what I also heard
from these employees was that most of
these responsible gaming measures are
not proactive they're typically reactive
there's typical intervention after the
damage has been done they're falling
behind on their mortgage they've run up
a huge credit card bill they're they're
feeling suicidal
for now the main requirement in many U.S
states is that companies provide
helpline numbers and avoid marketing to
people on what's called self-exclusion
lists
there are some companies that have done
some Innovative things with their apps
you know they collect enormous amounts
of data they see how their users gambled
DraftKings and FanDuel collect huge
amounts of data on their customers and
they're able to track their customers in
ways that casino bosses would have only
dreamed of
while that data is used for simple
things like confirming customers age and
location it has other applications as
well
these companies are not simply gambling
companies they're technology companies
and they collect and use data in the
same way as other big technology
companies
or 100 a technology companies that's the
background that you know myself and my
co-founders come from we do obviously
have a lot of information about what
users do on our platform so what bets
they make what sports they're interested
in we use that information to help run
our business better
as you use the app you're tracked in
ways that we're familiar with from
social media sites and other internet
sites the companies have a good idea of
your net worth from the other websites
you visit from Google analytics data
State Regulators allow the companies to
profile customers based on betting
histories and limit the size of some
Wagers expected to win much like
traditional casinos kicking out Sharps
from the blackjack table
where we limit customers for a variety
of reasons some of them are because we
have particular customers that we think
take advantage of certain weak lines and
things like that obviously we want
people to win that's an important part
of the experience so we've never really
shut off a customer for that reason but
we also have to limit our risk exposure
too
ultimately by leaving it up to the
states and with no federal legislation
on the horizon these organizations for
the most part are left to police
themselves the vast majority of
companies are taking these apps and
they're tuning them they're turning them
to a hundred uh in terms of maximizing
Revenue they build in little or no
responsible gambling features the
federal government is more focused on
alcohol and opioids than gambling at
this point
the state level expansion of sports
betting has been accompanied by a lot of
lobbying but rarely has that lobbying
included strong responsible gambling
Provisions or problem gambling funding
the gaming industry writ large loves to
say there is no evidence you know
research-based evidence that points to
any one intervention or any one form of
Regulation the main research that's been
done is funded by the industry itself
and the industry prefers to focus on
Research that looks at individual
responsibility rather than the potential
responsibility industry and marketing
you know these products bill after Bill
that we've seen introduced since 2018
has been very specific about tax rates
and the number of licenses and every
other aspect of sports betting but
somehow curiously problem gambling
responsible gallon gets left out
while individuals ultimately bear the
responsibility for their own actions
many hope the biggest companies in this
area will make safety an Ever bigger
part of their mandate if only to assure
this boom doesn't end anytime soon I
think we can meet this moment I think
it's going to take a lot of hard work
it's going to take a lot more investment
by the industry but that's starting to
come around